[Music]
hello I'm van Wattenberg on this edition
of think-tank we will talk one-on-one
with social critic and economist Thomas
Sol of the Hoover Institution Tom Saul's
new book the vision of the anointed
argues that the assumptions and beliefs
of America's liberal elites have created
30 years of disaster in education crime
and welfare policy
what are these assumptions are they
wrong
where are they leading us a conversation
with Thomas Sol this week on think-tank
[Music]
joining us today is Thomas Saul a senior
fellow at the Hoover Institution at
Stanford University he is the author of
many books that have cast a critical eye
at American society including inside
American education and race and culture
his latest book the vision of The
Anointed self-congratulation as the
basis for social policy has been called
a broadside against the received wisdom
of America's elite liberal
intelligentsia Tom so why don't you
start out and tell us what the vision of
the anointed is about what is it well
it's one a vision that the problems that
we see in the world I do too the fact
that other people it's just not as
bright or as compassionate as they are
and that there are all these solutions
out there waiting to be discovered and
they have them and that these solutions
that are being posed upon the rest of us
by the power of government through
taxation law in other ways and what's
really crucial about it is that the
passion is so so much greater than the
patient on the other side largely
because what they have involved is more
who is today oh the media elite the
academically political elites and I and
the reason we can talk about their
vision even though they obviously vary
in their opinions is that the basic set
of underlying assumptions about the
world are very similar and because these
assumptions are the prevailing
assumptions the need to find evidence
for them or to offer proof is much less
if something happens they'll explain it
in a way which will fit that vision for
example when they find that prenatal
care has less among blacks than among
whites and that infant mortality rates
are higher they immediately assume
there's a progressive societies neglect
and therefore if only the government
will step in provide more prenatal care
that problem solves itself but in
reality other groups have even less
prenatal care than blacks and don't have
any more mortality than whites but they
don't ever get to that second stage
because once they've seen something that
fits their conception of how the
works that's sort of the end of it let
me go back to that idea of who the day
is no I mean in your cosmology are these
liberals is that what they are yes the
New York Times The Washington Post
Harvard Stanford no the Edward Kennedy's
the all the usual suspects let me but
it's more than those particular people
but my mindset goes back at least 200
years who does it start with what is I
don't know where it starts but you can
even find it in the 18th century you if
you read William Godwin inquiry
concerning political justice in 1793 you
have the whole vision laid out just as
it was in the 1960s but the 1960s were a
crucial point because that's when this
vision became dominant this sort of
arrogant vision that we know best oh yes
and don't even have to subject it to
normal forms of brew oh absolutely not
absolutely not let me read you something
that speaker Gingrich wrote in his book
to renew America he said since 1965
there has been a calculated effort by
cultural elites to discredit this
civilization and replace it with a
culture of irresponsibility that is
incompatible with American freedoms as
we have known them mm-hmm do you buy
that is that basically what yes oh I
would I would limit that to those who
are sort of at the top of this kind of
thing the cost further down that people
believe things because so many others
believe them because they're in the air
and so on but you know I was
particularly interested in what he said
was that it is a calculated effort this
now do you believe that the people be
anointed as you call them are sitting
around in a conspiratorial mode
calculating as Newt Gingrich says and
saying here's what we're gonna do or do
you just think they're wrong and this is
what they believe and they have this
certain arrogance about because it's two
very different yeah this is why I made
the distinction between the leaders and
the others I mean I think that when
people say things like more American
wives are battered on Superbowl Sunday
you see than any other time of the year
and and there's not a speck of evidence
for that that is calculated because
they're conditioned oh I mean you say
they're yours there is no data that
could even be misinterpreted that way in
other words because there is no data
period and so yes but I think that 99%
of the people who believe it or not
calculating mm-hmm I think I think one
of the reason that it flies without
without even being challenged for
evidence is that there is a certain
vision of how the world is and in that
world men are oppressing women and
therefore when you say something like
this it fits the vision and that's the
end of it there's no there's no demand
for evidence you have in your book sort
of a series toward the beginning of how
the actual process works of forming one
of these ideas and selling it and
rejecting the proof maybe you could just
kind of watch it through this as a model
of it all right there's a four stage a
pattern and in the first phase that's
what's what I call the crisis and so
we're a hype to believe that something
is a terrible crisis for which something
must be done and what was what was
fascinating to me and doing the research
for the book is it very often the thing
that's said to be in crisis has often
been getting better for years on in but
that gets ignored in the second stage
and for example infant mortality to use
one well I'm thinking about Frank
teenage pregnancy in vain' and venereal
disease are those things were getting
better teenage pregnancy was going down
for more than a decade before sex
education was introduced venereal
disease syphilis in 1960s was only had
only half the incidents that had in 1950
so all these things are going down yet
that was said to need sex education to
deal with this crisis which is then
manufactured and again this is where the
calculated part comes in
now the 99% of the people who hear this
don't know that and but the reason they
accept it is because they also share the
same vision and because this is
consonant with that vision they don't
have to ask for overnight so what's
what's stage to that Stage two is the
first one is there's a crisis yes
establish a crisis usually an artificial
one yes then then stage two is the
solution you have a solution for this
crisis in this case you have sex
education in the school
and then at that point P you say if we
do this this will lead to beneficial
result a the critics say no it'll lead
to detrimental results z stage 3 you put
it into the results you put it in and
directly you find detrimental results
the namely venereal disease and teenage
pregnancy take off into the stratosphere
and then stage 4 is the fascinating part
and which they simply say no that
doesn't prove that this was a bad policy
because there were many factors there's
complexity it's simplistic to blame it
on this but they run through this
routine on so many different things
including crime similarly they said you
know in 1960 Judge Bazelon said we just
desperately need to have some kind of
change in the criminal justice system
now in 1960 there were fewer murders
than they had been in 1950 1940 or 1930
but again that was completely ignored
and so now we have the revolution in the
criminal justice system people say no if
you have put these new things in
there'll be more crime than before
they put them in almost instantly the
declining crime rate turns around and
heads up again and they say no it's
simplistic to blame this on on this
there are the root causes and the
neglect of society and all the rest of
it so it's heads I win tails you lose
so to go to that earliest example that
you gave you think the increase in
venereal disease was caused by sound
okay say that I don't even have to
believe that all I have to say is delay
it but do you oh I think I I think it's
hard to explain otherwise I mean you
know you don't get social changes that
drastic in a cut in a few years without
some particular cause but I thought that
the arguing doesn't depend on that at
all the point is they created the crisis
artificially the evidence shows there
was no crisis and when and what they
would not even subject it to any
empirical test if they want to show some
other fact that came in and really
caused this I'm happy to hear that and
why would a group of liberal
intellectuals or politicians or media
stars or whatever why would they sit
around and decide to dismember or dilute
the criminal justice system if
I thought in advance that it would raise
the amount of criminality oh they did
they didn't think that but the point
they just thought wrongly that it would
be that it would help yes but but it
would also give them an enormous Lee
larger role than they had before I mean
a judgement just sits there and applies
the laws that have been passed by the
legislature has a very minor role but if
he takes the expansive judicial activist
role then of course he's on the leading
edge and he can look for the hosannas
and all the rest of his life how does
this play out in the realm of something
else you have written about which is
affirmative action exactly how does that
process what's the one two three four on
that I I haven't worked it out like that
but certainly there is no interest
whatever in finding out empirically
whether things have been made better or
worse for minorities as a result of this
program and in fact if you bring them up
evidence they all say ah but things
would have been even worse had we not
done this similarly with the war on
poverty well you can show how dependency
on government was going down poverty was
going down before this program was ever
put in and within a few years dependence
on government was going up and after a
few more years the absolute number of
people in poverty was going up yeah I I
read that in your book but the absolute
number of poverty is not the relevant
the data the relevant data would be the
rate of poverty rate of poverty and in
fact in the nineteen said I worked for
President Johnson so we have to
establish the the the line we took was
that during the 1960's during the
kennedy johnson administration poverty
did in fact go down sharply and and then
the rate since then not the absolute
number because the country has grown
larger the rate has sort of bounced
around at about flat somewhere between
twelve yes but don't forget don't forget
this was sold to the country not on the
grounds that if you transferred money
from A to B that B would have more money
that was not the argument the argument
was that dependency would be reduced
that you would quote invest in people as
Bill Clinton is now saying now that
people have forgotten what was said in
the sixties this will then you give them
job training and all those kinds of
things parenting skill
the whole bit and this will then be an
investment that will pay off in the
future because there'll be fewer people
dependent upon the government and they
were before and I go through a great
number of people from John F Kennedy
Lyndon Johnson the new york times again
all the usual suspects said all these
things Lyndon Johnson was not a usual
suspect well he was the primary suspect
all right but the fact is that was never
tested and when you when there were all
these wonderful retrospectives held down
in Texas and other places about this the
first order of business is to evade the
criterion that they themselves set up
when they set this out and so no matter
what happens if the originates a failure
by the original criterion then we just
find another criterion by which it will
be a success well let's just examine
that for a minute I have a friend of
mine from those old White House days was
listening to again Gingrich shortly
after we had this great Republican
revolution in in nineteen ninety-four a
great meaning you'd not necessarily
wonderful we shall see about that and he
kept hearing Newt Gingrich used the word
opportunity his conservative
opportunities society we have to provide
opportunity and and I was talking to me
said you know Gingrich uses that word
opportunity almost as much as Johnson
did which is what you're saying that
that was the rhetoric it was called the
equal oh it was the Office of Economic
Opportunity that's what it was now so if
if liberals were talking about
opportunity and now conservatives are
talking about opportunity and I'm sure
you're for opportunity longest children
all God's children got opportunities so
what is your problem
that that liberal said we ought to
create programs for opportunity and in
point of fact I mean just to no I won't
say play devil's advocate because I mean
a lot of the things that that came out
of the Great Society been building all
those junior colleges and community
colleges so I would disagreement on I
think it was a tragedy look first now it
was a tragedy yes why is that a tragedy
have millions of people who have
absolutely no desire for an education
using up billions of dollars of the
taxpayers money
and not only not getting an education
themselves making it more difficult to
give an education to those people who
came to college with an idea of getting
one now you say they have no desire for
education I mean nobody is hurting them
into these community colleges and into
the junior college they whoa I mean they
have a desire obviously no they do not
obviously because lots of things go on
in this places that are not education I
mean where else can you find so many
young people over the others same age
and an opposite-sex in one place a nice
convenient place to be but anyone who is
taught and these and a lot of these
places this this ferocious desire for
education as such is not terribly
visible and I taught at places where
we've gotten you know the upper ten
fifteen percent of students I mean UCLA
and whatnot and me neither I know my
colleagues found this great desire for
education as such they wanted to be an
ivy-covered buildings for four years in
order to get more money when they
graduate and have a good time while
they're there so you think the the great
American ideal which has really been
shared by both parties and both
ideologies over recent decades to allow
more people to get into higher education
that that is a bankrupt idea so to allow
is one thing but to subsidize people at
enormous cost with no real sign that
this is producing which what we entirely
they say when say subsidize I mean you
talk about a junior college a community
college
I guess that's subsidized it's it's it's
it's below cost sure a tuition but it
does allow kids who do not have the
money to go to Amherst or wherever to
start a college education I mean they
believe that before the Great Society I
did it before the Great Society my whole
generation did it before the Great
Society you are saying that the the
great humanitarian political impulses of
the 1960's have been almost without
exception bad well there was some some
good ones but I'm saying that the
assumption that on the education front I
mean I would defy you to find a large
number of people who have actually
taught these students who really think
that they're out there thirsting for
knowledge
have you if you if you're those they are
thirsting for a better job and we've set
up a society where you have to be
credentialed with a certain amount
alright so can't aren't they able to get
a better job no no there's an ontology
of composition you know if one person
stands up in the stadium he sees the
game better but if they all stand up
they don't all see the game better as
long as you know if you have if you have
a degree and the other guy doesn't then
you get ahead of him in the employment
line but we're not gonna all get ahead
of each other in the employment line by
all getting degrees so this whole idea
that I guess again both liberals and
conservatives are saying is that at this
particular moment 1995 we have to get
more people into the education system
because that's the way to compete and we
looked at the data and we see that the
people with more education are earning
more money than ever before relative to
the people with less education people
that's all a fallacy of everybody
standing up in the stadium able to fly
on the Concorde kids who flown on the
Concorde undoubtedly will make more
money than people who kids who've only
going on buses that does not mean if we
put a lot of people on the Concorde
we're gonna raise the national income we
would increase the revenues of the
concorde yes and which they desperately
need of course right that's another
story
all right now and just to review the
bidding you date the the the full-blown
nature of this this situation sort of in
the 1960s is that right yes I say
everyone on the conservative side start
I mean Genesis is mid 1960s that's when
the world started I mean and I'm not
arguing with that was in the fall in the
garden right okay all right now since
the 1960s the United States of America
has won the Cold War
remained a while a lot of people
including a lot of mostly conservatives
are saying all America's lost its nerve
and we canwe because well not only
elbows the Conservatives well that I
recall a an issue of the public interest
in in the mid 1970s saying has America
lost its nerve mmm a whole bunch of
conservatives saying oh my god it's
terrible well is it to be quite as well
maybe that's right but but so since this
terrible event thirty years ago when the
sixties dropped upon us we we've won the
Cold War we we've continued to grow in
affluence in professional skills we have
absorbed about 20 million immigrants we
are the wealthiest freest country in the
history of the world you would agree
with all of that is roughly well III
disagree entirely with your base period
no no no I'm Simon I tried all those
things that you talk about began long
before the 1960s they fault a little
talk to a great extent on the Jimmy
Carter they were they were they were
resumed with a renewed vigor in the
1980s under an entirely different kind
of kind of vision but I'm talking about
the social decline of the country
because the social decline is all the
more striking because here's the country
that is prosperous you can't blame the
crime rate on the fact that there's more
poverty there's less poverty there's
more affluence it's not due to
foreigners because as you say we've won
the Cold War all the normal things that
you might blame all this on aren't there
it's not because of diseases because
science has conquered more diseases it's
all because of self-inflicted wounds and
I'm saying these are the people who
inflicted those wounds and this is why
we shouldn't listen to him anymore what
are the nature of those wounds crime no
no I the integration of the family the
disintegration of the educational system
and those and it's not going to matter
we will be like the man who gained the
whole world and lost his soul is there a
common root to all of those all of those
problems other than you heard them from
the annointed class I mean is there
something is it yes what the government
is that one no no it's the notion that
ordinary people cannot be trusted to
make the decisions that they've been
making but these must be preempted
either by judges in the case of crime by
the schools taking over the
indoctrination of other people's
children behind their back and in
and against there a protest or what was
what was the other one the family
putting taking money from the taxpayers
and subsidizing behavior as well as
encouraging it and legitimizing behavior
that has turned out to be enormously
self-destructive undermining the family
in a thousand different ways
Tom you write in your new book division
of the annointed available at all
bookstores about the Teflon profits yeah
who what what is well I think my
favorite is Paul early because he's been
so consistently wrong on so many things
one predicting mass starvation I think
was the 70s of the 80s but predicting
and we're running out of running low on
resources and Julian Simon made this
famous bet with him and he would bet
offered about anybody $1,000 that they
could name a set of resources and name a
period of time and at the end of that
period of time those resources would not
be more expensive as they would be if
they were really running low but would
be either stationary or falling in real
terms and Ehrlich rushed in with his
list of 10 resources and I would come
back in the ten years at the end of ten
years not only was the bundle of ten
resources cheaper in real terms and it
was before every single resource he name
was cheaper let me raise a final point
here you make this vigorous attack in
the vision of the anointed that we
should no longer listen to these people
that's sort of the bait they've been
wrong it's they don't prove their points
it's hurt us who should we listen to we
should listen first and foremost to our
own experience you seem to activate with
there there must be alternative saviors
we should stop looking for saviors I
mean the society has not existed for
thousands of years because it had a
succession of saviors it's existed
because it has institutions and
processes through which people can
realize their own goal I understand that
but but EE but you are attacking people
who would like to lead us and tell us
how the world works no no no no they
don't want to tell us how the world
works
then why they want to take over the
decisions for us they don't tell the
parents how they ought to teach sex
education their children they put this
material in the schools behind the backs
of the parents with instructions not to
let the parents see it okay but that's
the problem but we live in a in an open
and democratic society now mr. and mrs.
John Q public are listening to this
program I hope and they're saying well
that guy really makes a lot of sense in
turn but basically it's been a negative
proposition don't listen to these people
don't do this don't do that no no don't
let those people run you a lot okay but
how do you how do you practically as a
non-problem a nobody happen those people
are adults just like you and me okay
they have been running their lives for
thousands of years they don't need me to
tell them what today but this is a
souther question I want to take over
from people on the left but I want them
to continue to make make their decisions
as they see fit right but but but this
is a democracy they have to have to vote
they can realize that they see if this
should they vote for oh good they've
been voting for whoever they want or -
without my years but some of these
people are voting for the people who are
listening to these anointed people I
mean yeah I might give my audience some
advice so here in 1994 without any help
for me whatsoever
they changed who they voted for it was a
non-problem you say without any help to
you but you and your confreres in the
conservative movement I think have had
an influence but it wasn't because
although this book obviously we're not
because of this book but because of your
earlier wonderful books it talks all
thank you very much and thank you please
send your questions and comments to New
River media one one-five-zero 17th
Street Northwest Washington DC - zero
zero three six we can also be reached by
email at think TV at aol.com or on the
worldwide web at www.puppetsnstuff.com
for think-tank I'm been wattenberg
[Music]
[Music]
this has been a production of BJ W
incorporated in association with New
River media which are solely responsible
for its content